wenn ich jetzt ein politiker bin mit
gemäßigten meinungen habe ich dann
überhaupt eine chance gegen die afg oder
sollte ich direkt umsatteln auf muffin
rezepte und tierfotos oder fotos von
pflanzen und der inhalt kommt dann an
zweiter stelle
viele grüße aus berlin morgen ist
vatertag und am sonntag ist muttertag da
geht es um das engagement es ist
definiert als die die summe der likes
die nutzer unter beiträgen oder post
verlassen plus kommentare in relation
zur anzahl der produzierten inhalte an
die frage ist jetzt katze gut oder eher
baum und strauch katzen im tierheim in
nürnberg bei den deutschen politikern
bis da noch bedarf was zu machen
ja es wenn wir die follower zahlen
anschauen dann könnte man ja wohl meinen
dass vielleicht eher beauty blogger die
nächsten politiker werden wir müssen den
politikern helfen das machen ja und zwar
jetzt
[Musik]
walter genau mit th das überhaupt also
das ist eine influenza lehrer von einer
berliner influenza schule das glaube ich
nicht
doch wirklich was halten sie jetzt hier
von herr schulz von dem profil vormann
hofreiter kamera da noch was machen auf
den ersten blick müssen wir auch mal
sagen starkes titelbild weil sieht also
wasser macht auch das positioniert er
sich gut übrigens super branding
grundsätzlich vom auftritt sowie so
konsistent merkt man sich leicht also
sehr soziale medien geeignet würde ich
sagen entschuldigung wollte mich
verarschen
[Applaus]
haben sie instagram ich hatte meinen her
frucht man normal veranstaltung die die
jusos da gemacht hatten einen hinter mir
stehen jungen mann eine andere schulter
und dann habe ich den angehörigen bei
den jusos nähe sagte bei instagram wir
wollen jetzt mal schauen wie sie ihr
instagram profil aus was kann man da
machen ja sehen sie mich zur halbzeit
und dienstlich ein wahnsinn oder
heute sehen wir den herrn lindner aus
ganz unterschiedlichen blickwinkeln wir
schon noch ein bisschen traurig nicht
traut das ist müde lassen sich immer
gegen 2 uhr im ausschuss nachts gegen 2
uhr hat der mann noch bei insidern
gepostet ist das gut vorbildlich tapfer
was würden sie dem hellen noch empfehlen
was könnte der machen dass die fotos ein
bisschen mehr durch die decke gehen
grundsätzlich an fotos stil arbeiten
also sind sind gut aussehen da
charismatischer mensch
die gucken so sehr überrascht ja ja das
hat mir meine frau noch nie gesagt
dann ist für mich sozusagen facebook er
der informative teil und twitter der an
dem ich ganz kurz wo sich politisch
agieren ja und so da kamen zuletzt auch
die großen shitstorm es dann bin ich
dann aber einen fünftausender zahlen ist
auch im bereich schützt der sechziger
darum sehr gut
also geschützt doch maschine ist
fantastisch ist es gut geschützt ist
eine schlimme sache zum letzten hilft
immer ich bin absoluter fan nicht nicht
von ihnen aber von ihren profilen es
geht um instagram und sie sind so
sensationell gut wie machen sie das
das da gibt es so ein knopf so ein knopf
hier auf dem display
wenn sie da draufdrücken wird ein foto
ausgelöst der mann ist absoluter bruch
wieder machte er ein foto von mir für
sein profil ich werd verrückt wird jetzt
gepostet kann ich ihnen das noch
untersagen recht eine einzige
persönlichkeit des öffentlichen lebens
wie soll das denn gehen
das heißt ich bin jetzt auch wenn sie
nicht ins privatleben zurückziehen
dann wäre es möglich aber ich glaube sie
müssen auch von was leben alles klar ab
jetzt sehe ich mich um
[Applaus]
[Musik]